Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The epic return of Yellowstone is now streaming exclusively on Paramount+. You destroy me, you destroy yourself. Unlike you, I keep my promises. The wait is over. Yellowstone, new episodes now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。史诗级大剧《黄石》回归，现已在 Paramount+ 独家播出。你毁了我，你也毁了你自己。跟你不同，我向来信守承诺。等待已经结束。《黄石》全新剧集现已在 Paramount+ 独家上线。
This episode is brought to you by Missouri from November 25th to December 2nd. Get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks. Missouri has something for everyone Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials So you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them shop your wishlist 25% off at mazuri.com today Hey guys, you know what this playground could use a wine country, huh? A redwood forest would be cool.
本期节目由 Mejuri 赞助。11 月 25 日至 12 月 25 日，在 Mejuri 史上最大规模的促销活动中，单笔订单满 150 美元即可享受全场 75 折优惠。从夸张的大耳圈到极简的叠戴首饰，Mejuri 总有一款适合你。Mejuri 采用负责任采购的原料，为您打造适合日常佩戴的手工高级珠宝，让您在赠送和佩戴时都倍感舒适与自信。今天就登录 mejuri.com，以 75 折优惠选购您的愿望清单吧。嘿，伙计们，你知道这个游乐场需要什么吗？一片葡萄酒产区，哈？红杉林应该会很酷。
Ski slopes! Wait! Did we just invent California? Discover why California is the ultimate playground at VisitCalifornia.com. On the quarterdeck of the Vanguard, a slim, slender man in his late thirties, pale and sandy haired, bowed his head in silent prayer. At long last, God had given Horatio Nelson the battle he wanted. Now on every ship in the fleet, the drums were pounding, and every face was glowing with eagerness, excitement, and just a hint of nerves.
滑雪场！等等！我们刚刚发明了加利福尼亚吗？访问 VisitCalifornia.com，探索为什么加利福尼亚是终极游乐场。在“先锋”号的后甲板上，一个三十多岁、身材修长、面色苍白、留着沙黄色头发的男子微微低头，默默祈祷。历经漫长的等待，上帝终于赐予了霍雷肖·纳尔逊他梦寐以求的战役。此刻，舰队中的每一艘战舰上，战鼓雷动，每一张脸上都洋溢着渴望、兴奋，甚至还带有一丝紧张。
On his flagship, Nelson turned to face the east. The light was fading, but for the first time in months, he felt happy. All his life he had been preparing for this moment. Now was his chance to join the heroes of history. He did not intend to waste it. So ladies and gentlemen, Forrester O'Brien Sandbrook, modern masters of prose who have brought the age of Nelson to life. And that of course was from Nelson Hero of the Seas by our very own Dominic Sandbrook, describing the scene on the evening of the 1st of August, 1798,
纳尔逊在旗舰上转身面向东方。天色渐渐暗了下来，但几个月来他第一次感到快乐。他一生都在为这一刻做准备。现在是加入历史英雄行列的机会了。他可不打算白白浪费。女士们先生们，福雷斯特·奥布莱恩·桑德布鲁克，将纳尔逊时代活灵活现地展现在我们面前的现代散文大师。这段话当然摘自我们多米尼克·桑德布鲁克所著的《海上的英雄纳尔逊》，书中描述了 1798 年 8 月 1 日傍晚的场景，
as the British fleet sails towards the Battle of the Nile. Dominic, unbelievable drama. It is an incredibly melodramatic scene, Tom. The sun setting over the coast of Egypt. The Nile. And the Nile. Yeah, this place of legend, this place of classical history, which is the classical history that has fascinated so many people in the late 18th century.
当时英国舰队正驶向尼罗河战役。多米尼克，这戏剧性简直难以置信。这是一个极其具有戏剧张力的场景，汤姆。夕阳西下，照耀着埃及海岸。尼罗河。还有尼罗河。是的，这片传奇之地，这片古典历史之地，正是这片古典历史在 18 世纪末吸引了如此众多的人。
And now on the greatest stage of all, Horatio Nelson is meeting his moment of destiny. So listeners who've stuck with us from the beginning of this series will remember that Nelson had been sent into the Mediterranean with a squadron of 14 ships of the line to search for Napoleon Bonaparte and the armament, this enormous fleet and expeditionary force that has been sailing south. The British didn't know where it was going. They missed the French by an hour and a day. The French landed in Alexandria.
而现在，在最大的舞台上，霍雷肖·纳尔逊迎来了他命运的时刻。因此，从本系列一开始就一直关注我们的听众会记得，纳尔逊曾被派往地中海，率领由 14 艘主力舰组成的舰队，搜寻拿破仑·波拿巴以及那支庞大的舰队和远征军，后者正向南航行。英国人并不知道它要去哪里。他们与法国人擦肩而过，只差了一天一个小时。法国人在亚历山大港登陆。
They seized control of Egypt. Napoleon marched into Cairo as the master of the sands. Really? And then, Nelson arrived in Alexandria on the morning of the 1st of August. He saw the tricolor flags flying over the city, the city founded by Alexander, the city of the Ptolemies. Nelson sends a couple of ships east to see if by any chance the French fleet are still there. And the lookouts spot the fleet in Abu Kirba, the midshipman George Elliott, 16 years old up there on the yards, sees the masts and the hunt is over.
他们夺取了埃及的控制权。拿破仑作为沙漠之王开进了开罗。真的吗？然后，纳尔逊于 8 月 1 日清晨抵达亚历山大港。他看到三色旗在城市上空飘扬，那是亚历山大大帝建立的城市，是托勒密王朝的城市。纳尔逊派了数艘船向东驶去，看看法国舰队是否还在那里。瞭望员在阿布基尔湾发现了这支舰队，16 岁的见习军官乔治·埃利奥特在横桁上看到了桅杆，搜寻结束了。
They have found them and the signal reaches the rest of the fleet at 2.45 in the afternoon, signalled from the zealous 16 sail of the line at anchor bearing east by south. And for Nelson's captains who have been despondent that they missed the French, it is a moment of almost transcendent excitement that they have at last found them. And it is what Nelson has been looking for, isn't it? A chance to launch not just a battle, but a battle potentially of annihilation and to give the French commanders their due. They knew that if they were found by Nelson, this is what he would try and do. And so they had strongly argued
他们找到了敌人，信号在下午 2 点 45 分传达给舰队的其他部分，由“狂热”号发出——16 艘主力舰下锚，方位东偏南。对于一直为错过法国人而沮丧的纳尔逊的船长们来说，这是一个近乎超然兴奋的时刻，他们终于找到他们了。这正是纳尔逊一直在寻找的，不是吗？不仅是一场战役的机会，更是一场潜在的歼灭战的机会，也算是对法国指挥官们的回应。他们知道，如果被纳尔逊找到，他就会这么做。因此他们曾极力争辩，
that the fleet withdraw up to Greece and Napoleon had overruled them. So it is Napoleon himself who has given Nelson and the British fleet their great chance. Yeah. And Napoleon's hubris frankly, Tom, it's a theme that runs right through Napoleon's career. Obviously most people regard Napoleon as one of the most brilliant commanders in history, but he is often reckless and heedless of danger. I think it's fair to say.
主张舰队撤退到希腊，但拿破仑否决了他们。所以正是拿破仑本人给了纳尔逊和英国舰队这个绝佳的机会。是的。说实话，汤姆，拿破仑的傲慢贯穿了拿破仑的整个职业生涯。显然，大多数人认为拿破仑是历史上最杰出的指挥官之一，但他往往鲁莽且无视危险，我认为这样说并不过分。
And in this occasion, it's his sailors that will pay a very heavy price for that. Because right from the beginning, the British, there's no doubt in their minds at all. I think this is the extraordinary thing. We talked about this in our episode about the Battle of Capus and Vincent, where they'd fought the Spanish. There seems to be, of course, they're nervous as they know the battle is coming, but there's an extraordinary expectation of inevitable victory, isn't there? There's a scene on the Orion, the ship of one of Nelson's most talented captains, James Sommaray. They've been having dinner, so dinner is early afternoon. And the story is that literally the steward is clearing
而在这次事件中，他的水兵们将为此付出沉重的代价。因为从一开始，英国人就毫不怀疑。我认为这是最不可思议的地方。我们在关于圣文生角战役的节目中讨论过这一点，当时他们与西班牙人作战。当然，他们知道战斗即将来临时也会紧张，但似乎有一种对必然胜利的非凡期待，不是吗？“猎户”号上有一个场景，那是纳尔逊最有才华的船长之一詹姆斯·萨马雷的船。他们一直在吃晚餐，晚餐是下午早些时候。故事说，管家 literalmente 在清理，
the table in the captain's cabin and they hear the news. They all jump to their feet. They're just kind of shaking hands and slapping each other in the back. They're so excited. Hazards, I believe, are heard. Hazards are heard and they drink a toast. They drink a bumper, as they call it, to victory because they're so certain that this is their moment and then they clamber up the ladder and Samurai gets up onto the deck and the crew have heard the news too and the crew are roaring out three cheers for their captain, for their country and for crew have heard the news too. And the crew are roaring out three cheers
船长舱里的桌子，然后他们听到了消息。他们全都跳了起来。他们只是在握手、互相拍拍后背。他们太兴奋了。我相信听到了干杯声。听到了干杯声，他们举杯祝贺。他们喝了一大杯他们所谓的“胜利酒”，因为他们确信这就是他们的时刻，然后他们爬上梯子，萨马雷登上甲板，船员们也听到了消息，船员们为他们的船长、为他们的国家、为船员们也听到了消息而高声欢呼。船员们高呼三次，
for their captain, for their country and for their certain victory. And Sommaray is reckoned to be one of the more lugubrious of Nelson's captains. So I mean, imagine what it's like on Trowbridge's ship or, you know. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Or Alexander Ball, the Robinson Crusoe fan. Another officer said, we felt the utmost joy that the hunt was over. Now they're going to fight and they are absolutely buzzing with excitement. And that joy, that is the Nelson touch, isn't it? The conviction that he shares their sense of joy and that by going on the attack, they are doing what he wants to do. Absolutely. And that the entire fleet is essentially kind of thinking as one.
为了他们的船长，为了他们的国家，为了他们必胜的信念。而萨马雷被认为是纳尔逊手下比较郁郁寡欢的船长之一。所以，想象一下特罗布里奇的船上是什么情况，或者，你知道的。没错。没错。或者亚历山大·鲍尔，那个《鲁滨逊漂流记》迷。另一位军官说，搜寻已经结束，我们感到无比喜悦。现在他们要战斗了，他们兴奋得热血沸腾。这种喜悦，就是纳尔逊的风格，不是吗？坚信他与他们分享这种喜悦，并且通过发动进攻，他们正在做他想做的事。绝对是的。整个舰队基本上都心意相通。
Exactly. Because this is the interesting thing, right? It is now almost three o'clock in the afternoon. It's the first of August, but there's probably only about four hours of daylight left before the light really begins to fade. Even if Nelson rushes from Alexandria, it will still take him about two hours to reach the enemy. So in other words, they don't have much time and they will be doing a lot of the fighting in gathering darkness. And also they don't know the waters and they will be doing a lot of the fighting in gathering darkness. And also they don't know the waters, do they?
没错。因为有趣的是，现在已经是下午三点多了。今天是八月一日，但在天色真正开始变暗之前，大概只有大约四小时的白昼了。即使纳尔逊从亚历山大港全速赶来，也仍然需要大约两个小时才能抵达敌人所在处。换句话说，他们没有多少时间，而且大部分战斗将在渐渐暗下来的夜色中进行。而且他们对那片水域并不熟悉，他们将在渐渐暗下来的夜色中进行大部分战斗。而且他们对那片水域并不熟悉，不是吗？
They don't know the waters. One or two of them have French charts of the waters, but this is unfamiliar territory. They know that there are shoals and the shoals will be playing an important part in the story to come. Yes. I know you're very excited about your opportunity to show off your knowledge of the sandbanks of Abu Ghir Bay, Tom. Certainly am. And nautical terminology that I have picked up over the years that we've been
他们对那片水域并不熟悉。其中一两个人有法国绘制的海域海图，但这是陌生领土。他们知道那里有沙洲，而这些沙洲将在即将上演的故事中扮演重要角色。是的。我知道你非常兴奋能有机会展示你对阿布基尔湾沙洲的知识，汤姆。我当然很兴奋。还有我这些年一直在学习的航海术语，
doing the rest of history. Wonderful. You know, people love cutting edge research and you've been doing it since 2020. All your life has been leading to this hour. When I began this podcast, I couldn't have told you what port meant. You know, maybe a drink, but nothing more. But now, yeah, absolutely got it at my fingertips. Wow. People like Roger Knight, John Sugden, Andrew Lambert, the great naval historians in it. They will be listening to this podcast in more. Wrapped.
我们一直在做历史的剩余部分。太棒了。你知道的，人们喜欢前沿研究，你从 2020 年就开始做了。你的一生都在为这个小时做准备。当我开始这个播客时，我甚至不知道“港口”是什么意思。你知道的，可能是一种饮料，仅此而已。但现在，是的，绝对是信手拈来。哇。像罗杰·奈特、约翰·萨格登、安德鲁·兰伯特这样的伟大海军历史学家。他们会更专注地听这个播客。入迷。
So different commander would have waited till the next day. So you mentioned John Sugden. Yeah. He says of Nelson, I think correctly, it was not in the admiral's nature to dither with an enemy in sight. Not at all. So I give that my stamp of approval. It's very Alexander the Great at the Battle of the River Granicus, Tom. You know, he arrives in, it's dark and he says, attack anyway. This is the same thing. Nelson said, I knew I could go for it because I had total trust in my captains and my men. I had the happiness to command a band of
所以，换作别的指挥官，肯定会等到第二天。所以你提到了约翰·萨格登。是的。他评价纳尔逊时说，我认为很准确，在敌人视线之内犹豫不决绝不是这位海军上将的作风。一点也不。所以我对这一点举双手赞成。这非常像亚历山大大帝在格拉尼库斯河战役中的作风，汤姆。你知道的，他到达时天已经黑了，他说，不管怎样，进攻。这完全是一回事。纳尔逊说：“我知道我可以全力以赴，因为我对我的船长和手下的官兵有绝对的信任。我有幸指挥着一群兄弟。”
brothers. Therefore night was to my advantage. Each knew his duty and I was sure each would feel for a French ship. But Dom, do you know who this is very bad news for? The French, Theo. It's bad news for the French, but it's also bad news for the Bullocks who've been brought all the way, all the way from Sicily and who now get chucked into Abakir Bay. Right, because the order goes around, beater quarters, it's like the scene in Master and Commander at the beginning. What that means is everybody rushes into action, they stow the hammocks, they stow every bit of furniture, they pour water on the timbers because they want to stop any possibility of fire spreading, they throw down sand on the decks to stop
因此，黑夜对我有利。每个人都知道自己的职责，我确信每个人都会为一艘法国船而战。但是多姆，你知道这对谁来说是个极其糟糕的消息吗？法国人，西奥。这对法国人来说是个坏消息，但对那些被一路从西西里岛带过来、现在却被扔进阿布基尔湾的公牛来说，也是个坏消息。没错，因为命令下达了，各就各位，就像《怒海争锋》开头的那个场景。这意味着每个人都冲向战斗岗位，他们收起吊床，收好每一件家具，他们在木结构上浇水，因为他们想阻止任何火势蔓延的可能性，他们在甲板上撒沙子以防
people from slipping. Again, if you've seen Master Commander, you'll know the scene that the surgeons are laying out their swords, the carpenters get their tools. Yeah. And of course warming up their tools because this is something that Nelson's commanded because he remembers what it's like to have cold steel sliced through bone. Exactly. And on the gun decks, which are the most important bits of course of the ship, people are getting everything ready, preparing the cannons, getting their balls, getting the power, everything ready. And meanwhile, you know, slowly but surely, they are moving east towards the anchored
人们滑倒。同样，如果你看过《怒海争锋》，你就会知道外科医生在摆放他们的手术刀，木匠们准备工具的场景。是的，当然还要加热他们的工具，因为这是纳尔逊下令的，因为他记得冰冷的钢铁切过骨头是什么感觉。没错。而在炮甲板上——当然是战舰最重要的部分——人们正在做好一切准备，准备大炮，准备炮弹，准备火药，一切准备就绪。与此同时，（你知道的）他们缓慢但坚定地向东移动，驶向锚泊的
French fleet. So let's turn now to the French. The French have 13 ships of the line. The flagship is this enormous ship called Lorient, the Orient, commanded by Vice Admiral Francois Paul de Prues. And Dominic, when you say it's enormous, I mean, it is larger than any ship in the entire Royal Navy. It's got 120 guns and on either side of it there are two 80 gunners. Now how many guns has Vanguard got, which is Nelson's flagship? Vanguard I think is a 74 isn't it? Something like that. Right, so all three of those ships have more than Nelson's flagship and the
法国舰队。现在让我们转向法国人。法国人有 13 艘主力舰。旗舰是一艘名为“东方号”（L'Orient）的庞大巨舰，由中将弗朗索瓦·保罗·德·布吕埃指挥。多米尼克，当你形容它巨大时，我的意思是，它比整个皇家海军的任何一艘船都要大。它有 120 门大炮，两侧各有两艘 80 门大炮的战舰。“先锋”号——也就是纳尔逊的旗舰——有多少门大炮？“先锋”号我想是一艘 74 门炮的战舰吧？差不多吧。没错，所以这三艘船的火炮数量都超过了纳尔逊的旗舰，而且
two ships on either side, Le Tonneau, so the Thunderer and Le Franklin. Oh no, named after the tax Le Franklin. Oh no, named after the tax resistor. Yeah, so there's an incentive. Yeah, definitely. Kill two birds with one stone there. The best British ships are their 74s because they're the perfect balance between firepower and speed and maneuverability. Some of these hulking monsters that the French and the Spanish go in for, as we will see in battle, are actually not as effective. But just to emphasize, I mean, they do have, I think, a marginal superiority in firepower. So there is, I think, again, this is from John Sugden, the 17 ships, so there are, as well as the 13 ships of the line, there are four frigates which are stationed behind them
两侧的两艘船，“勒托诺”号（即“雷霆”号）和“勒富兰克林”号。哦不，是以那个纳税抗拒者命名的。勒富兰克林号。哦不，是以纳税抗拒者命名的。是的，所以这是一个激励。是的，绝对的。一石二鸟。英国最好的战舰是他们的 74 门炮舰，因为它们是火力、速度和机动性之间的完美平衡。法国人和西班牙人所热衷的一些笨重庞然大物，正如我们将在战斗中看到的，实际上并没有那么有效。但需要强调的是，我的意思是，他们在火力上确实拥有微弱的优势。所以，我认为，再次引用约翰·萨格登的话，这 17 艘船——除了 13 艘主力舰外，还有四艘护卫舰部署在它们后面的
in the line. They carried a nominal total of 1,182 guns firing 26,740 pounds of metal, a firepower exceeding that of the Grand Armée that Napoleon took into Russia in 1812. Wow. I mean, so quite intimidating. Yeah. Shall I describe the French line and all that and where it is? I think everybody would love that. I think everybody would love that. So you talked about Briers who's in command and he is of aristocratic background, but he's an enthusiast for the revolution. And even though obviously he's come under suspicion, he's too good for them to let go. And so he's in command. And there is another man of noble descent who like Briers was a sympathizer with the revolution and had renounced his kind of nobility. So he had been Pierre Charles de Villeneuve and is now just Pierre Charles Villeneuve. And he is a man who will be featuring throughout the story of Nelson. But at this point,
队列中。它们名义上共携带了 1,182 门火炮，能够发射 26,740 磅重的金属弹药，其火力甚至超过了拿破仑在 1812 年带入俄罗斯的大军。哇。我的意思是，相当具有威慑力。是的。需要我描述一下法国的阵型以及它的位置吗？我想每个人都会喜欢的。我想每个人都会喜欢的。所以你谈到了担任指挥官的布吕埃，他出身贵族，但他却是革命的热心支持者。尽管他显然受到了怀疑，但他实在太优秀了，以至于他们不愿放过他，所以他依然担任指挥官。还有另一个人，他也是贵族出身，同布吕埃一样同情革命并放弃了自己的贵族身份。所以他曾经是皮埃尔·查尔斯·德·维尔讷夫，现在只是皮埃尔·查尔斯·维尔讷夫。他将在纳尔逊的故事中频繁出现。但在此时，
he is in command of the rear guard on board a ship called the Guillaume Tell, so William Tell. Brias is in the middle. And then you have what is called the LARBORD, which is apparently the left line. So just to set the scene, Abakir Bay, there is a castle and a kind of promontory, Abakir Castle, and then the bay kind of curls around and heads eastwards and towards Rosetta, which is the place where the famous Rosetta stone in due course will be found. And the angle, if you drew a straight line from Abbekeir Bay to Rosetta, you'd be going from north-northwest to south-southeast. And this is the line that the French fleet is occupying, the 13 ships of the line, the four frigates are stationed
他指挥着一艘名为“纪尧姆·泰尔”（即“威廉·泰尔”）的船上的后卫部队。布吕埃在中间。然后是所谓的“左舷”（LARBORD），这显然是左翼队列。为了设定场景，阿布基尔湾有一个城堡和一个类似于岬角的地方，即阿布基尔城堡，然后海湾向外弯曲，向东延伸，朝着罗塞塔方向延伸——著名的罗塞塔石碑就是在那里被发现的。如果我们从阿布基尔湾到罗塞塔画一条直线，这个角度将是从北-西北到南-东南。这就是法国舰队所占据的阵型，13 艘主力舰，四艘护卫舰部署在
behind them. So you have nearest Abakir castle, that's the Labrador side. It is protected all around its seams by shoals. So you have shoals to the south of the castle and you have shoals spreading eastwards. And there's an island called Becquiais, which in turn is surrounded by further shoals. So the British fleet, to reach the French line, they have to negotiate these shoals. And Bries is assuming that the Labrador side, so the side that is furthest towards Abaquer Castle, that it can't be outflanked because it seems to be protected by the shoals. And that is his assumption. Yeah. His thinking is that the British attack will come from the seaward side because his
它们的后面。所以距离阿布基尔城堡最近的是“左舷”一侧。它的四周都有浅滩保护。城堡的南面有浅滩，东面也有浅滩延伸。这里有一个叫贝基耶的小岛，岛周围又被更多的浅滩环绕。因此，英国舰队要接近法国战舰的队列，就必须穿过这些浅滩。而布吕埃假设“左舷”一侧——也就是最靠近阿布基尔城堡的那一侧——不会被包抄，因为它似乎受到浅滩的保护。这就是他的假设。是的。他的想法是，英国人的进攻将来自面向大海的一侧，因为他的
line is kind of parallel to the coast and there's no way he thinks the British can get round between his ships and the land and attack from that side. So all the preparations are towards the sea. And so the ships that are closest to the shoals on the Labud side, Guerrier, so warrior, conquerant, conqueror, Spartiet, Spartan, bristling names. In fact, some of them are a bit ropey. So conqueror, it's 52 years old, it's very under man, it's kind of lacking in armaments. But I think that the French naval command assume this won't be a problem because first of all, it will be very difficult for the British
阵型基本上与海岸平行，他认为英国人绝不可能绕到他的战舰与陆地之间并从那一侧发动进攻。因此，所有的防御准备都是针对大海方向的。因此，左舷侧最靠近浅滩的战舰——“勇士”号（Guerrier）、“征服者”号（Conquérant）、“斯巴达人”号（Spartiate），这些名字听起来令人毛骨悚然。事实上，其中一些船只状况有点糟糕。比如“征服者”号，已经有 52 年历史了，人员严重不足，武器装备也有所欠缺。但我认为法国海军指挥部认为这不是问题，因为首先，英国人很难
to negotiate the islands and the shoals to actually get at the French line. And above all, it will be impossible for them to outflank them and get behind the rear. This is the assumption. That's right. So, where's his plan basically? He knows that his crews aren't as good as the British crews. They've been short of food and fresh water. They haven't been terribly well treated by Napoleon. Morale is not brilliant, but he thinks, yeah, the last thing therefore I want to do is to sail out and face the British in the open seas. Because it's a defensive position. Yeah. We're nicely against the bay. We'll stay where we are, let the British come onto us and then we just blast them out of the sea and they will disperse and that's how
穿过岛屿和浅滩来真正攻击法国战舰的阵型。最重要的是，他们绝不可能包抄他们并绕到后方。这就是他们的假设。没错了。所以，这就是他的基本计划。他知道自己的船员不如英国船员优秀。他们一直缺乏食物和淡水。他们没有受到拿破仑很好的对待。士气不是很高，但他认为，是的，我最不想做的事情就是开出海湾，在公海上面对英国人。因为这是一个防御阵地。是的。我们紧靠着海湾。我们就待在这里，让英国人自己攻过来，然后我们把他们轰出海面，他们就会溃散，这就是我们
we will win the day. And also just to say that there is also cannon in the castle, so that's an additional risk for any attacking force. Yeah. So he gives his order. And the French are all rushing to their battle stations, but all on the side facing the sea. With the wind and the wind is blowing the British fleet towards them. That's right. So now it's half past four, the sun is sinking fast on they come Tom, the pride of the Royal Navy sailing in perfect order towards the lengthening shadows. That's just a taste of the pros you can expect in this landmark book.
赢得胜利的方式。还要顺便提一下，城堡里也有大炮，所以这对任何进攻部队来说都是额外的风险。是的。于是他下达了命令。法国人全都冲向各自的战斗岗位，但所有的目光都转向面向大海的一侧。顺风而行，风正吹拂着英国舰队向他们驶去。没错。现在是四点半，夕阳正在迅速下沉，他们来了，汤姆，皇家海军的骄傲以完美的阵型驶向越来越长的阴影。这只是你可以从这本划时代的书中期待的散文的一小部分。
Nelson flies his favorite signal, prepare for battle. And then he's, then he flies a second crucial signal and I think everybody would enjoy it Tom, if you explain precisely the technological and tactical nuances of the second signal, which is to anchor from the stern once within range. What does that mean? It's very simple. Anchoring from the stern means that if a ship is sailing before the wind, so the wind is blowing it onwards, you reach a point, you come to a sudden halt and you hold your course
纳尔逊升起了他最喜欢的信号旗：准备战斗。然后他又升起了第二个至关重要的信号旗，汤姆，我想如果由你来精确解释第二个信号旗的技术和战术细微差别，大家都会很感兴趣的，那就是一旦进入射程就从船尾下锚。这是什么意思？很简单。从船尾下锚意味着，如果一艘船顺风航行——也就是说风推着它向前——你到达某个点时，会突然停下来，并保持你的航向，
so that you remain broadside on to the ship that you're firing on without kind of veering around. Without swinging. Without swinging. So in other words, the French fleet are anchored. The British fleet wants to get to a position where their cannon will be as devastating as possible. To do that, they want to anchor as well. So they come bombing along and essentially it's like a kind of sudden break.
这样你就能与你开火的敌舰保持侧舷相对，而不会四处乱晃。不会摇摆。不会摇摆。换句话说，法国舰队下锚停泊了。英国舰队想要到达一个位置，使其大炮的威力达到最大。为了做到这一点，他们也需要下锚。所以他们气势汹汹地冲过来，基本上就像是一个急刹车。
Yes. Like an emergency stop or something. Yeah. It's like an emergency stop, but you know, you're not kind of swinging around with the shock of it. Yeah. And this is a technique that Nelson himself has developed. Yes. And he's developed the signal for it himself because it's never been done before. And the thing is, it sounds like, well, why is that so complicated to just stop in front of the enemy and shoot at them? But actually, to anchor by the stern means basically you
是的。就像紧急停车一样。是的。就像紧急停车一样，但你知道，你不会因为那种冲击力而四处乱晃。是的。这是纳尔逊本人开发的一种技术。是的。而且这个信号也是他自己开发的，因为以前从未有人这么做过。问题是，这听起来像是在敌人面前停下来朝他们开枪有什么复杂的？但实际上，通过船尾下锚意味着基本上你
come on, you come on, you come on. And at a given moment, the sailors have to furl the sails to slow the ship. They drop this massive anchor, 20 tonnes, from the stern of the ship. And then you run down below decks and you get to your guns because obviously there's a risk. The moment you stop, then you're easier for the enemy to shoot at you. And you have to do this all within a question of seconds, minutes, maximum. In the dark and with shoals all around. And the point is, if it works, you'll be perfectly placed to hammer the front. You'll have stopped right next to them, broadside on and bang, you can go for it. If it doesn't work, you are totally vulnerable and the French will be able to blast you out of the sea.
不断前进，不断前进，不断前进。在某个特定时刻，水手们必须收起船帆来减慢船速。他们从船尾抛下这个重达 20 吨的巨大船锚。然后你跑到甲板下面去操作大炮，因为显然有风险。你停下来的那一刻，敌人射击你就更容易了。你必须在几秒钟、几分钟、最多几分钟内完成这一切。在黑暗中，周围全是浅滩。关键是，如果成功了，你将处于完美的位置去痛击敌人的前卫。你将停在他们旁边，侧舷相对，轰的一声，你可以全力开火。如果失败了，你将完全暴露，法国人就能把你轰出海面。
Or you might run into an island or a shoal or a sand bank or whatever. Exactly. And Nelson knows that nobody else in the world can do this. That there is only one fleet that is so well trained, so disciplined, so well provided for, so well prepared. And that's the Royal Navy. Nobody else could dream of doing such a maneuver under such intense pressure. So on they go, that is the instruction at about 10 to five.
或者你可能会撞上岛屿、浅滩、沙洲什么的。完全正确。纳尔逊知道世界上没有其他人能做到这一点。只有一个舰队受过如此良好的训练、如此纪律严明、备战如此充分、准备如此周全。那就是皇家海军。在如此巨大的压力下，没有人敢梦想进行这样的机动。所以他们继续前进，那是大约四点五十分时的指示。
One more signal. He says, concentrate your fire on the enemy front and center. When we've dealt with them, we move on to the enemy rear, which is under Villeneuve, as you said. Also, Dominic, just to say that the wind that is blowing the British towards the French also mean that it will be quite difficult for Villeneuve to come up to the centre, should they need support. That's right. So now they're approaching the shoals and sandbanks at the entrance to the bay. And once they're past them, they can turn to engage the French. The sun is now
还有一个信号。他说：集中火力攻击敌人的前锋和中央。当我们处理完他们之后，我们再转向由维尔讷夫率领的敌军后卫，正如你所说的那样。另外，多米尼克，补充一句，将英国人吹向法国人的风，也意味着维尔讷夫如果需要支援的话，很难赶到中央支援。没错。现在他们正在接近湾口处的浅滩和沙洲。一旦越过这些浅滩，他们就可以转向迎战法国人。太阳现在
beginning to set. You imagine the scene captured in so many paintings actually afterwards, this blood red glow across the shore of Egypt. And it does have a really, I mean, when I was writing about this in the book, you're blown away by the epic feel of it because this is the kind of territory for which Roman Carthage fought. Yeah. Well, you know, literally in the waters underneath the battle, there are statues and columns from Ptolemaic temples and buildings. I mean, just kind of littering the bay.
开始落山了。你可以想象一下后来许多画作中捕捉到的场景：埃及海岸上一片血红色的微光。当我写到这部分时，那种史诗般的感觉确实会深深地震撼到你，因为这正是罗马和迦太基曾为之战斗过的领土。是的。嗯，（你知道的） literalmente 在战斗下方的水域里，散落着来自托勒密神庙和建筑的雕像和圆柱。我的意思是，这些东西散落在海湾里。
And of course, both Nelson and Napoleon see themselves as actors in a drama to rival the greatest stories of the classical world, don't they? So it's the most appropriate setting. It's unbelievable. And you know, this is going to be the greatest naval battle of the 18th century in terms of scale and in terms of the drama of the tactics. Absolutely it is. So 530 Nelson sends another signal, form the line as most convenient into the line of battle. The first ship to go around the sandbanks is Thomas Fowler's ship Goliath. And so when you say the sandbanks, these are the sandbanks and the shoals that are extended out from the island of Becquieu that has to be negotiated so that they round that and
当然，纳尔逊和拿破仑都把自己看作是一场戏剧中的演员，足以媲美古典世界最伟大的故事，不是吗？所以这是最合适的背景。真是令人难以置信。你知道，这将是 18 世纪规模最大、战术戏剧性最强的海战。绝对是这样的。因此，在 5 点 30 分，纳尔逊发出了另一个信号：根据最方便的队形组成战列线。第一艘绕过沙洲的船是托马斯·福利的“歌利亚”号。所以当你提到沙洲时，这些是从贝基耶岛延伸出来的沙洲和浅滩，必须绕过它们，
then they can sail directly towards the French line. Exactly. So Foley is leading the way with Samuel Hood, no relation. Well, he is a relation, but he's not the same as the Samuel Hood from a couple of episodes ago in the zealous close behind. Now Foley has a map of the shoals published in 1764, a map published in Paris by a Frenchman, the irony. And as he goes round the sandbanks into the water, he realizes this thing about Pouillet's line that the French have left a gap between themselves and the shore. So the labored side. The labored side, exactly. So this line that Pruess had thought was impregnable couldn't be outflanked,
然后他们才能直接驶向法国战舰的阵型。没错。因此，福利带着塞缪尔·胡德（毫无亲戚关系——好吧，他是亲戚，但和几集前的塞缪尔·胡德不是同一个人）在“狂热”号上紧随其后。现在，福利手里拿着一张 1764 年出版的浅滩地图，那是法国人在巴黎出版的地图，多么具有讽刺意味。当他绕过沙洲进入水域时，他意识到了布吕埃阵型的一个特点：法国人在自己和海岸之间留下了空隙。也就是左舷侧。左舷侧，完全正确。所以布吕埃认为坚不可摧、无法被包抄的这个阵型，
can be outflanked, but only if you have an absolute mastery of seamanship. So what you'll need to do is glide between the French and the shore. That would allow you to open fire from the shore side onto the French where the French crews have not bothered to prepare their guns. Because it hasn't crossed their minds that the British could outflank them and therefore kind of crush them between two walls of fire. Exactly. So what Foley does in the Goliath, he goes around the leading French ship, he's raking it as he goes and then he does exactly as Nelson planned. At the given moment, they furl the sails, the sailors drop this massive 20-ton
实际上是可以被包抄的，但前提是你必须对航海术有着绝对的精通。所以你需要做的是在法国战舰和海岸之间滑行。这将允许你从海岸一侧向法国人开火，而法国船员根本没有费心去准备那一侧的大炮。因为他们做梦也没想到英国人会包抄他们，从而将他们夹在两堵火墙之间粉碎。没错。所以福利在“歌利亚”号上所做的是，他绕过了打头阵的法国战舰，边走边对其进行侧射，然后他完全按照纳尔逊的计划行事。在特定时刻，他们收起船帆，水手们抛下那个重达 20 吨的巨大船锚，
anchor and then they sprint downstairs to their gun decks, to their cannons and open fire. Pouring fire, all this metal, the cannonballs, the metal, the shrapnel, whatever, into the sides of the first French ship. And just to say also about the French ships, the French aim at the masts, the British don't, they aim at the decks. But having said that, it takes six minutes for the Guerrier's foremast to come down. And this is the first concrete sign for all the British ships that are following that this tactic is working.
然后他们冲下楼梯，跑向他们的炮甲板和加农炮并开火。将所有的金属、炮弹、弹片等火力倾泻到第一艘法国战舰的侧舷上。顺便说一句，关于法国战舰，法国人瞄准的是桅杆，而英国人不这么做，他们瞄准的是甲板。话虽如此，“勇士”号的前桅仅仅用了六分钟就被击断了。这给所有随后跟进的英国战舰释放了一个明确的信号：这个战术奏效了。
There's great cheer along the line of the fleet. And it's evident that Nelson's plan essentially forced him ahead. Yes, because as Foley anchors, other British ships are continuing past him. So each ship will take the next position further on in line next to the French ship. And actually the only British ship that doesn't make it round the shoals that are stretched westward of this island of Becquieu, So getting into the open sea that would enable him to attack the French is Trowbridge's Culloden. So the kind of the great fire brand of Nelson's captains. He's
舰队队列中爆发出一阵巨大的欢呼声。很明显，纳尔逊的计划基本上强行推进了。是的，因为当福利下锚时，其他英国战舰正继续从他身旁驶过。因此，每一艘战舰都将在阵列中占据紧邻法国战舰的下一个位置。事实上，唯一一艘没有绕过贝基耶岛向西延伸的浅滩——
the only one who can't get to grips with them. But I think you could argue in his defence, somebody was always going to do that and he is able to then signal to the two ships behind, watch out. I mean somebody had to do that at some point I guess. So Nelson does not blame him as we will see in due course for this at all. So five ships have done that flanking movement that we were talking about Tom, going on the side nearest the shore. And meanwhile Nelson's vanguard leads the attack from the other side, the seaward side. So what that means is the French are now trapped, they're sandwiched between two lines of British ships taking
从而无法进入能够攻击法国人的公海——的英国船，是特罗布里奇的“卡洛登”号。也就是纳尔逊手下那些脾气火爆的猛将之一。他是唯一一艘无法与敌舰交火的船。但我想你可以在他的辩护中说，总得有人去做这件事，而且他随后能够向后面的两艘船发出信号：小心。我的意思是，我想总得有人在某个时刻去冒这个险。所以正如我们随后将看到的，纳尔逊一点也没有责怪他。因此，五艘战舰完成了我们刚才讨论过的包抄机动，汤姆，从最靠近海岸的那一侧前进。与此同时，纳尔逊的先头部队从另一侧（即面向大海的一侧）发动进攻。这意味着法国人现在被困住了，他们被两列英国战舰夹在中间，两面受敌，
damage from both sides. And if we just take a minute to imagine the scene, what an unbelievable kind of canvas this is. This huge red setting sun, Nelson's ships blasting away, the gun crews presumably at this point absolutely sodden with sweat. I mean to be down there below decks, the cannons, the thunder, the soot, the gun smoke that's choking your lungs, people are shouting and screaming the whole time as the French of course are firing back, splinters flying through the air, blood everywhere, bodies piling up on the decks around you. And yet this is what the Navy does. They are so disciplined. They are just
遭受着双重打击。如果我们花一分钟想象一下这个场景，这是一幅多么令人难以置信的画作啊。巨大的红色落日夕阳，纳尔逊的战舰火力全开，此时炮手们想必已经大汗淋漓。想象一下在甲板下面，大炮的轰鸣声、煤烟、呛得肺部生疼的硝烟，法国人反击时人们一直在大喊大叫，弹片在空中飞舞，鲜血四溅，周围甲板上堆满了尸体。然而，这就是海军的作风。他们纪律严明。他们只是
loading and loading and loading and firing and firing and firing. And of course, if it's bad, you know, to be in the Royal Navy, it's even worse for the French ships who are caught between these two lines of metal smashing into them. So I think already, but even by the time that Vanguard is taking up its position, the two French ships on the Labrador side are pretty much already completely wrecked. So that's Guerrier and Conqueror. I mean, they're kind of crippled pretty much beyond repair, but goodness, they fight bravely too. Oh, they do. Yeah, absolutely. They do.
不断地装填、不断地装填、不断地装填，然后不断地开火、开火、开火。当然，如果说在皇家海军服役已经够糟糕的话，那么对于被夹在两道猛烈轰击的金属火力网中间的法国战舰来说，情况就更糟了。所以我想，甚至在“先锋”号就位之前，左舷侧的两艘法国战舰就已经几乎完全被毁了。那就是“勇士”号和“征服者”号。我的意思是，它们基本上已经残破不堪，但天哪，它们也打得非常英勇。哦，确实如此。是的，绝对如此。
The Guerrier will keep fighting for three hours. You know, all the masts have gone. British captains are kind of calling out, surrender, surrender. They just keep on. And, you know, this battle is a terrible battle because the French, although essentially they're in a horrible position, they do not give up. They don't at all. And they're inflicting great punishment, by the way, on the British ships. So there's a story about on the Goliath, for example, there's a boy sailor who is just about to put his match to his gun when the French open fire, the enemy broadside literally tears his hand from his body and the story goes, and it's one of those stories that Hollywood wouldn't invent
“勇士”号将持续战斗三个小时。你知道，所有的桅杆都断了。英国船长们大声喊着“投降吧，投降吧”，但它们就是不肯屈服。而且，你知道，这是一场可怕的战斗，因为法国人尽管基本上处于糟糕的境地，但他们绝不放弃。他们一点也不放弃。顺便说一句，他们也给英国战舰造成了极大的杀伤。所以有一个故事说，例如在“歌利亚”号上，有一个水手男孩正准备把火把凑近大炮时，法国人开火了，敌人的侧舷齐射 literalmente 把他的手从身体上撕了下来，故事是这样说的——这是好莱坞都编不出来的那些故事之一——
it is that he just reaches down with his surviving hand, he picks up the match, which is still burning, and fires the gun. He makes sure to fire the gun with his other hand before going downstairs to find the surgeon with kind of blood streaming from where his right hand had once been. The pluck of British youth, Dominic. Absolutely, it says, Tom. And I would hope that reading this book, British youngsters will feel inspired to behave similarly under pressure. Sure it will. So meanwhile, Nelson's vanguard is also taking horrific punishment.
他只是用剩下的那只手够过去，捡起那支还在燃烧的火把，发射了大炮。他在下楼去找外科医生之前，确保用另一只手发射了大炮，当时鲜血正从他曾经长着右手的地方喷涌而出。英国青年的勇气，多米尼克。绝对的，汤姆说。我希望读到这本书的英国年轻人能受到启发，在压力下表现出同样的风范。肯定会的。与此同时，纳尔逊的先锋部队也遭受了惨重的打击。
French fire rips through the rigging, there is shrapnel and splinters everywhere, the timbers are soaked with blood, and then Nelson is hit. At 8.30, a jagged piece of iron among the hail of splinters and shrapnel comes spinning through the air so fast that there is no time to duck and it smacks into Nelson's head and he is down, blood pouring from a gash in his head and like a character in an opera he shouts, I am killed, remember me to my wife. wife. And the men rushed to his side. They carry him down to the cockpit. The surgeon wipes away the blood.
法国人的火力撕裂了索具，到处都是弹片和木屑，木结构被鲜血浸透，然后纳尔逊负伤了。8点30分，在密集的木屑和弹片雨中，一块锯齿状的铁片以极快的速度在空中旋转着飞来，快得让人根本来不及躲闪，它狠狠地砸中了纳尔逊的头部，他倒下了，鲜血从头部的伤口中喷涌而出，就像歌剧里的角色一样，他大喊：“我牺牲了，请代我问候我的妻子。”妻子。部下们冲到他身旁。他们把他抬到下层船舱。外科医生擦去血迹。
It's actually just a surface wound. It's an extremely gory surface wound because the shrapnel has sliced open his head for three inches, but it's effectively a flesh wound as long as it's not infected. He shouldn't have any trouble. It's not like he's lost his arm, is it? He hasn't lost his arm or indeed another eye. And it's nothing compared with the shattered bones and severed limbs of his comrades, and he will soon be back on deck for the end game.
这其实只是一个表皮伤。这是一个极其血腥的表皮伤，因为弹片把他的头皮划开了一个三英寸长的口子，但只要不感染，它实际上只是个皮肉伤。他应该不会有什么大碍。这又不是断了一条胳膊，对吧？他没有失去手臂，也没有失去另一只眼。与战友们粉碎的骨头和被切断的四肢相比，这根本不算什么，他很快就会回到甲板上迎接最后的决战。
And we will be back after the commercial break to look at that end game. This episode is brought to you by Missouri. This episode is brought to you by Missouri. From November 25th to December 2nd, get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks, Missouri has something for everyone. Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials so you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them. Shop your wishlist 25% off at majurie.com today. Hey, uh, was someone supposed to turn off the Black Friday deals?
我们在广告休息后将回来观看那场最后的决战。本期节目由 Mejuri 赞助。本期节目由 Mejuri 赞助。11 月 25 日至 12 月 2 日，在 Mejuri 史上最大规模的促销活动中，单笔订单满 150 美元即可享受全场 75 折优惠。从夸张的大耳圈到极简的叠戴首饰，Mejuri 总有一款适合你。Mejuri 采用负责任采购的原料，为您打造适合日常佩戴的手工高级珠宝，让您在赠送和佩戴时都倍感舒适与自信。今天就登录 mejuri.com，以 75 折优惠选购您的愿望清单吧。嘿，呃，是不是有人应该关掉黑色星期五的优惠？
Oh, for fuck's sake, really? They're still on? Yeah. And that's deals on, like, a ridiculous amount of resorts, right? Yeah. And they're some of the lowest prices we've had all year? Yeah. Well, we're in it lowest prices we've had all year? Yeah.
哦，操他的，真的吗？它们还在进行？对。而且那些折扣涉及，比如说，数量惊人的度假村，对吧？对。而且它们是我们全年见过的最低价格之一？对。好吧，我们现在身处其中。
Well, we're in it now. How should we spin this? Um, Sunwing's Black Friday deals are still on, so book before they're gone for good. How's that? That'll do. You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it.
我们该怎么包装这个？嗯，Sunwing 的黑色星期五优惠仍在继续，所以趁它们永远消失前赶紧预定吧。这样行吗？这就够了。你知道雄心壮志最棒的地方是什么吗？你看不到它。
Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon, or they could be late for the bus. You never know. Ambition is on the inside. So that road trip bucket list? Get after it. Drive your ambition. Mitsubishi Motors. The boy stood on the burning deck whence to all but him had fled. The flame that lit the battle's wreck shone round him, earther dead. Yet beautiful and bright he stood as born to rule the storm, a creature of heroic blood, a proud though childlike form. The flames rolled on, he would not go without his father's word. That father, faint in death below, his voice no longer heard."
有些事情看起来雄心勃勃，但表象可能是具有欺骗性的。例如，一个跑步者可能正在为马拉松进行训练，或者他可能只是赶公交车迟到了。你永远不知道。雄心壮志在内心。那么那份公路旅行心愿单呢？行动起来吧。驱动你的雄心。三菱汽车。那个男孩站在燃烧的甲板上，除了他之外，所有人都已逃离。照亮战斗残骸的火焰在他周围闪耀，他仿佛已经死去。然而他站得美丽而明亮，仿佛生来就是为了主宰风暴，一个拥有英雄血统的生物，一个骄傲却又像孩子般的身影。火焰继续蔓延，如果没有父亲的命令，他是绝不会离开的。那个在下方濒死的父亲，再也听不到他的声音了。”
So that was Casabianca by Felicia Dorothea Hemans published in 1826. She was by far the most distinguished female poet of the day. In fact, I should have done it in a Scouse accent, in a Liverpool accent, because that's where she came from. Then she went and lived in Wales. And I mean, that is one of the kind of classic Victorian poetic illustrations of pluck and heroism of the kind that the Victorians so adored. But French pluck. But French pluck, yes.
那是费利西亚·多萝西娅·海曼斯于 1826 年出版的《卡萨比安卡》。她是当时最杰出的女诗人。事实上，我应该用利物浦口音来读它，因为那是她出生的地方。后来她去威尔士生活了。我的意思是，那是维多利亚时代热烈推崇的那种勇气和英雄主义的经典维多利亚时代诗歌插图之一。但这是法国人的勇气。但这是法国人的勇气，是的。
So this is the story of the 12-year-old son of the captain on the French flagship Orient, Luc-Julien-Joseph Casabianca. So he's captaining the ship on which Brieze, the commander of the French fleet, is also using as his flagship. And the context for this is that the ship is burning. It has an enormous amount of gunpowder on it. So it is about to go up sky high, but the boy refuses to abandon his post because his father has told him not to move, but his father has been knocked unconscious. And so the boy just stands there to the bitter end. And shall I continue the poem? I'd love that Tom. Do you think listeners would enjoy
那么这就是法国旗舰“东方号”船长路易-朱利安-约瑟夫·卡萨比亚诺12岁儿子的故事。当时他正负责掌管这艘船，法国舰队司令布雷斯也将这艘船用作他的旗舰。而当时的背景是，这艘船正在燃烧。船上载有巨量的火药。所以它随时可能爆炸冲天，但这个男孩拒绝离开他的岗位，因为他的父亲告诉他不要动，然而他的父亲已经被震得昏迷不醒。于是这个男孩就这样一直站在那里，直到最后一刻。我还要继续念这首诗吗？我太乐意了，汤姆。你觉得听众会喜欢
that? Yeah, I think they'd love it too. Okay. Love a bit of Victorian melodrama. There came a burst of thunder sound. The boy, oh, where was he? Ask of the winds that far around with fragments, strewed the sea with mast and helm and pen and fair that well had borne their part. But the noblest thing which perished there was that young faithful heart. Oh, Tom, it's so moving. Thing is a lot of people genuinely kind of scoff at that and say,
这个吗？是的，我想他们也会喜欢的。好的。就爱看点维多利亚时期的情节剧。雷声轰鸣爆发。那个男孩，哦，他在哪里？去问问四处飘荡的风，它把碎屑散落在海面上，还有桅杆、舵、横桁和船舷，它们曾尽过自己的职责。但在那里毁灭的最崇高之物，却是那颗年轻而忠诚的心。哦，汤姆，太感人了。问题是很多人真的有点嘲笑这种说法，并说
madly overwrought Victorian verse. I can quite see why Victorians listen to that with tears running down their cheeks. I think it should be on the GCSE syllabus. Absolutely it should. So that's the fate of L'Oreal. And at the time, one of the most famous stories in the world, you know, the story of this boy in the English speaking world, everybody did this poem in school.
这是疯狂矫揉造作的维多利亚诗歌。我完全能理解为什么维多利亚时代的人听着会热泪盈眶。我觉得它应该被列入GCSE（英国中考）大纲。绝对应该。这就是“东方号”的命运。在当时，这是世界上最著名的故事之一，你知道的，在英语世界里这个男孩的故事，每个人在学校都学过这首诗。
However, we'll come back to L'Oreal. I mean, it is one of the most spectacular and tragic moments in naval history. The night is falling across the sands of Egypt. Tom, night is also falling on the ambitions of Napoleon Bonaparte. It is very difficult to talk about this battle without lurching into the ripest melodrama. So, let's just go for it and be unapologetic. So now, 8.30 or so. The ships on the Labrador side basically have been knocked out.
然而，我们待会儿会回到“东方号”上来。我的意思是，这是海军历史上最壮观、最悲惨的时刻之一。夜幕正笼罩着埃及的沙滩。汤姆，夜幕也正笼罩着拿破仑·波拿巴的野心。谈论这场战役时，很难不陷入最俗套的情节剧。所以，让我们直接开始吧，无需掩饰。现在大约是8点30分。拉布里亚多侧的战舰基本上已经被击溃了。
The first five French ships. So Spartiates, Tornon, Guerrier. And now they've got the ships in the middle of the line. So that is Lorient, of course, which we've just been talking about. This huge three deck ship, 120 guns, larger than any ship in the Royal Navy. And it's flanked on either side by Le Franklin and Le Tonneau, both of which also have more guns than the Nelson's own flagship. So might seem a tough nut to crack. It is. But Nelson's band of brothers are up for it. So the first to emerge through the smoke and the chaos is Bellerophon, captain by Henry d'Esteer, Darby. And this anchors at the stern just as planned, all guns blazing beside the French flagship.
头五艘法国战舰。比如“斯巴达人号”、“托尔农号”、“勇士号”。现在轮到战线中间的战舰了。当然就是我们刚才谈到的“东方号”。这艘巨大的三层甲板战舰，拥有120门大炮，比皇家海军的任何战舰都要大。它的两侧是“富兰克林号”和“雷长号”，这两艘船上的大炮数量也都超过了纳尔逊自己的旗舰。所以这似乎是一块难啃的骨头。确实如此。但纳尔逊的兄弟连已经准备好了。于是第一个穿过烟雾和混乱出现的是“柏勒罗丰号”，由亨利·德埃斯特·达比指挥。正如计划的那样，它在船尾抛锚，万炮齐发，紧挨着法国旗舰。
It is dwarfed by Lorion, but for half an hour or so Darby is just firing and firing and firing and he's taking horrendous punishment himself. Bellerophon suffers more casualties than any other British ship in the Battle of the Nile. Almost 200 men dead or injured. The sail slashed to ribbons, the mast cut down, Darby himself is knocked senseless with a head wound. But then after half an hour, two more British ships. Each British ship kind of cleans up a French ship, they can then move on to the next.
它在“东方号”面前显得像个小不点，但在大约半小时的时间里，达比一直在开火、开火、再开火，他自己也承受着可怕的打击。“柏勒罗丰号”在尼罗河战役中遭受的伤亡比任何其他英国战舰都要多。近200人死伤。风帆被撕成条状，桅杆被砍断，达比本人也因头部受伤而失去知觉。但在半小时后，又来了两艘英国战舰。每艘英国战舰基本上都解决掉一艘法国战舰，然后它们就可以转向下一艘。
So the Alexander and the Swift shore also close in on Lorient. By about nine o'clock, Lorient was in terrible trouble. So the deck is covered with splinters of wood and basically bits of French sailors. Now among them is the Admiral Brueyce himself. He has stood there the whole time under the most punishing withering fire. He was hit by British fire in the head and in the arm. Unbelievably, he takes a shot to the stomach that almost rips his body in two. And his men try to carry the two semi-detached bits of him down. And he says somehow through kind of blood pouring from his head, he says, no, I will die as I've lived on the deck of my
因此，“亚历山大号”和“斯威夫特肖尔号”也向“东方号”逼近。到了九点左右，“东方号”陷入了极大的困境。甲板上布满了木头碎片，基本上还有法国水兵的残肢断臂。其中就包括海军上将布雷斯本人。他一直在那里忍受着最严厉、最猛烈的炮火。他的头部和手臂被英国人的炮火击中。难以置信的是，他的胃部中了一炮，身体几乎被撕裂成两半。他的部下试图把他那两个半断开的身体抬下去。他一边从头部流血，一边不知怎么地说，不，我要像我的一生一样死在我的
ship. And he actually lives for another 15 minutes. I mean, amazing. And the commander of Le Tonneau as well. Just unbelievable. He loses both his arms and a leg and he carries on fighting as he slowly bleeds to death. I mean, I have to say throughout this story, indeed throughout Nelson's entire life and career, without exception, the French adversaries that he faces perform with outstanding courage under fire, because they're always outperformed by the British. They always know they will be, but they never give up. They don't run away. They don't haul down their colors straight away. They are fired by patriotism and a dedication to the service just as much as their British opponents are.
船的甲板上。他竟然又活了15分钟。我的意思是，太惊人了。“雷长号”的指挥官也是如此。简直难以置信。他失去了双臂和一条腿，在缓缓流血致死的同时还在继续战斗。我的意思是，我不得不说，在这整个故事中，实际上在纳尔逊的一生和职业生涯中，无一例外，他所面对的法国对手在炮火下都表现出卓越的勇气，因为他们总是被英国人压制。他们总是知道会这样，但他们从未放弃。他们没有逃跑。他们没有马上降下军旗。他们和英国对手一样，被爱国主义和对职责的奉献精神所鼓舞。
So it's nice to say something nice about our Gallic friends, isn't it, Tom? I think it reflects very well on you. Oh, Tom, that's correct. And on the sense of fair play of an Englishman. Yeah, it's a Corinthian spirit, isn't it really? So it reflects well on the French, but even more on us. So that's good. So let's get back to Lorient.
所以说点我们高卢朋友的好话挺好的，不是吗，汤姆？我觉得这很能说明你的问题。哦，汤姆，说得对。也体现了一个英国人的公平竞争意识。是的，这真是一种科林斯精神，不是吗？所以这很好地反映了法国人，但对我们来说更是如此。所以这很好。那么让我们回到“东方号”。
What did happen to the captain of Lorient, Casablanca? He was probably, some sources suggest, hit in the face by debris and he probably was knocked unconscious. And his son was on the ship with him. There are various accounts. Some say he's 10, some say he's 12, some say he's 13. He probably actually had, this is a horrible detail, had his leg torn off by a cannonball as he was standing next to his father.
“东方号”的船长卡萨比亚诺到底怎么了？一些资料表明，他可能面部被碎片击中，并可能失去了知觉。他的儿子当时和他在一起。有各种各样的说法。有人说他10岁，有人说他12岁，有人说他13岁。实际上，他可能遭遇了一个可怕的细节——当他站在父亲身边时，一条腿被一颗炮弹撕裂了。
So he probably didn't stand on the burning deck. Now at some point a midshipman on the Alexander spots a glow on the poop deck of Lorion, a lurid orange glow. Lorion is on fire. And there were different theories about what happened. Some historians think that Lorient was not properly cleared for action. And it had some jars of paint or oil on the poop deck that ignited in the chaos, in the flames. But Alexander Ball, the captain of the Alexander, said that he had prepared a kind of sort of
所以他可能并没有站在燃烧的甲板上。现在，在某个时刻，“亚历山大号”上的一名海军见习生发现了“东方号”尾楼甲板上的微光，一种阴森的橙色微光。“东方号”着火了。关于发生了什么有不同的理论。一些历史学家认为，“东方号”没有为战斗做好充分清理。在混乱和火焰中，尾楼甲板上的一些油漆罐或油罐被点燃了。但“亚历山大号”的船长亚历山大·鲍尔说，他准备了一种类似
Greek fire style. Byzantine liquid napalm. Yeah, combustible preparation. He had prepared in case of the direst emergency and that he said one of his lieutenants without his knowledge threw it at Lorient. The interesting thing there is there's a sort of sense that if that happened, it was illegitimate and it was unsporting. It was cheating.
希腊火风格的东西。拜占庭液体凝固汽油弹。是的，易燃制剂。他在最危急的情况下准备了这个，他说他的一名中尉在不知情的情况下把它扔向了“东方号”。有趣的是，有一种感觉，如果真的发生了这种情况，那是违法的，是不够体育精神的。那是作弊。
Isn't that extraordinary that they've got this thing which clearly was a super weapon and they're like, oh, it'd be very bad form to say that we used it. So the tenant did it, but I didn't order it. That kind of body line. Anyway, it's possible that it happened, right? Some bloke threw this through the windows of the Alexander onto Lorion. But the key thing is, is that Lorion, because it's so huge, therefore has a correspondingly vast quantity of gunpowder.
难道不奇怪吗，他们有这个东西，这显然是一种超级武器，他们却说，哦，说我们使用了它，形式太差了。所以是中尉干的，但我没有下令。那种甩锅行为。无论如何，这是可能发生的，对吧？某个家伙把这个通过“亚历山大号”的窗户扔到了“东方号”上。但关键是，“东方号”因为体型巨大，因此也相应地拥有海量的火药。
Exactly. And that's why, you know, it's not just people on the ship, but people all around are starting to think, hmm, this is looking a bit dodgy. Because this fire starts to spread very quickly. It goes up the rigging. Now the French, of course, have fire pumps aboard. All ships have fire pumps to try and deal with this. But the fire pumps have been smashed to pieces by British shot. A second fire begins at the bow and
没错。这就是为什么，你知道的，不仅仅是船上的人，周围的人也开始觉得，嗯，这看起来有点不妙。因为这场火灾开始迅速蔓延。它顺着索具往上烧。当然，法国人船上有消防泵。所有船只都有消防泵来试图处理这个问题。但消防泵已经被英国的炮火砸得粉碎。第二处火灾在船头开始蔓延，
that means that hundreds of sailors are trapped now in the waist of the ship and they can't get out. The British of course keep firing and firing all the time. The flames are leaping up the rigging of Lorion. Black smoke starts to pour from Lorion and at this point some of the sailors start trying to jump. They're kind of on fire or they're screaming or whatever. Now Nelson has been brought specifically back up even though he's got blood pouring from his head, he's got a kind of bandage on, to see this and he can see at once as everybody can that the French flagship, this enormous kind of Leviathan of the waters is doomed. That the fire is now raging unchecked and it will eventually, as you've said Tom, it will reach the magazine and ignite this enormous amount of gunpowder
这意味着成百上千的水兵现在被困在船腰部位，无法逃生。英国人当然一直在不停地开火。火焰在“东方号”的索具上跳跃。浓黑的烟雾开始从“东方号”喷涌而出，此时一些水兵开始试图跳船。他们身上着火了，或者在尖叫之类的。现在，纳尔逊专门被带回到上层甲板，尽管他头上流着血，还缠着绷带，来观看这一幕，他和所有人一样立刻就能看出，这艘法国旗舰、这只巨大的水上利维坦已经注定要灭亡了。大火现在已经失去控制地肆虐，正如你所说的那样，汤姆，它最终会蔓延到弹药库，并引爆海量的火药，
that the Orient is carrying. And so at about this point, when it's clear that the fire can't be stopped, the British and French captains on all sides are kind of rushing to cut their own anchor cables because they're going to be caught in the blast. They need to be carried away because when the fire reaches the magazine, there will be an explosion the like of which they have never seen before. And Nelson, to his great credit, I think, Tom, says to his lieutenants, prepare to pick up survivors.
而“东方号”正携带着这些火药。所以在差不多这个时候，当大火明显无法扑灭时，英国和法国的船长们各方都在争先恐后地砍断自己的锚链，因为他们将被卷入爆炸中。他们需要被带走，因为当大火到达弹药库时，将会发生他们从未见过的巨大爆炸。纳尔逊功不可没，汤姆，我认为他对他的中尉们说，准备营救幸存者。
This is what we do. I mean, this is, again, it's a sort of odd thing about fighting at sea that there is this code, isn't there, of kind of nobility, I guess. sea that there is this code, isn't there of kind of nobility? I guess there's so much against you isn't there got the enemy and you've got the sea. Yeah, exactly So about half nine hundreds of men are trying to jump from lorian But actually, of course a lot of these sailors cannot swim I mean, this is a theme of the master and commander series isn't it? They're patrick o'brien books plus it's very dark and You know those kind of bodies everywhere and bits of
这就是我们要做的。我的意思是，这也是海战中一种奇怪的事情，有一种密码，不是吗？某种贵族气派，我想。海战中有一种密码，不是吗？某种贵族气派，我想。有那么多不利因素，对吧？既有敌人，又有大海。是的，完全如此。所以大约九点半，成百上千的人试图从“东方号”上跳下来。但实际上，当然，许多水兵不会游泳。我的意思是，这是帕特里克·奥布赖恩的小说《怒海争锋》系列的一个主题，不是吗？加上天很黑，你知道到处都是那种尸体和残骸，当然还有……
course. Yeah, just terrifying. And then according to one account, at least it's a 937 that the fire reaches the magazine of L'Oreal. And that is the most unbelievable explosion. It's as though the entire French flagship just suddenly turns into this gigantic fireball and the searing kind of white heat of the explosion is felt by everybody across the bay. Just boom, this kind of burst. And it's heard for kind of miles around, seen for miles around, isn't this great kind of
是的，简直太可怕了。然后根据至少一份记载，在9点37分，大火蔓延到了“东方号”的弹药库。那是令人难以置信的爆炸。就好像整艘法国旗舰突然变成了一个巨大的火球，爆炸炽热的白热感被海湾对面的每个人都感受到了。只听轰的一声，这种爆发。方圆数英里都能听到，方圆数英里都能看到，这种巨大的
wall of fire spurting up into the sky. People in Alexandria hear it deep into the desert. I mean, astonishing. If a Hollywood filmmaker is listening, there are the most amazing descriptions. The whole thing is lit up suddenly. It is like it's midday because of the heat and light of this explosion. And the sailors can see suddenly for the first time that on the shore there are dozens, hundreds of Mamluk and Arab spectators who have been watching the battle unfold. Captain Miller of Theseus, he said, a most grand and awful spectacle such as formerly would have drawn tears down the victor's cheeks. But he says, pity was stifled as it rose by the remembrance of the numerous and horrid atrocities
火墙冲向天空。亚历山大港的人们在沙漠深处都能听到。我的意思是，太惊人了。如果好莱坞电影制作人正在收听，这里有最惊人的描述。整个场景突然被照亮。由于爆炸的热量和光芒，感觉就像正午一样。水兵们突然第一次看到，岸上有几十个、几百个马穆鲁克和阿拉伯旁观者，他们一直在观看这场战斗的展开。“忒修斯号”的米勒船长说：“这是一个最宏大、最可怕的景象，换作以前，会让胜利者的脸颊流下眼泪。”但他接着说：“随着对他们那个无原则、嗜血的国家过去和现在一直在犯下的无数骇人听闻的暴行的回忆，同情心刚刚升起就被扼杀了。”
that their unprincipled and bloodthirsty nation had been and were committing. And when she blew up, although I endeavored to stop the momentary cheer of the ship's company, my heart felt scarce a single pang for their fate. Nelson is softer hearted, isn't he? And they rescue what? About 70 survivors pulled up from the waters. And the thing that's amazing, always strikes me about this is that the sound is so deafening that for about 10 minutes everyone stops fighting. They're obviously the kind of, you know, the noise is ringing in everybody's ears and there is a kind of silence succeeds it because people can't carry on, you know, firing their
当它爆炸时，尽管我试图制止船员们短暂的欢呼声，但我的内心对他们的命运几乎没有一丝怜悯。纳尔逊心软一些，不是吗？他们营救了什么？从水里救出了大约70名幸存者。让我惊奇、一直让我震撼的是，声音震耳欲聋，以至于大约10分钟内所有人都停止了战斗。很显然那种声音在每个人耳边回响，随之而来的是一种寂静，因为人们无法继续开火
own guns. What's more, all they can hear is there's a steam, the hiss of the steam, but also the sound of thousands of fragments raining down on the waters. So bits of wood, bits of metal. And of course they are, I mean if you're in the sea and you have a bit of cannon fall on top of you. Yeah, an anchor fall on top of your head. That's not good, is it? No, not at all.
他们自己的大炮。更重要的是，他们能听到的只有蒸汽的嘶嘶声，还有成千上万碎片如雨般落入水中的声音。所以有木头碎片、金属碎片。当然还有，我的意思是如果你在海里，有一块炮弹落在你头上。是的，一个锚砸在你头上。那可不好，对吧？不，一点也不好。
There's an account by one lieutenant who wrote an account afterwards and he said, he wrote it in their present tense. So after about 10 minutes, as you say, they hauled themselves up from the decks where they've been taking cover and start firing again. And he wrote, and so the battle recommences and the roaring of the guns, the crashing of the masts and the shrieks of wounded and the jargon of surrendering Frenchmen fill up the remainder of this most memorable night." Yeah. And it carries on to what?
有一位中尉留下了记录，他后来写了一篇记录，他说，他是用现在时写的。所以在大约10分钟后，正如你所说，他们从躲避的甲板上爬起来，重新开始射击。他写道：“于是战斗重新开始，大炮的轰鸣声、桅杆的断裂声、受伤者的尖叫声和投降的法国人的嘈杂声，填满了这个最难忘的夜晚剩下的时间。”是的。一直持续到什么时间？
Kind of the early hours of the morning, one o'clock, two o'clock, something like that. Yeah, about two o'clock, I think. And essentially they're just too tired by the end. And this is good news for Pierre- Villeneuve aboard the Guillaume Tell, because he essentially, I mean, you said even the French have had a good fight. I mean, he hasn't really, he could have come up and help, but he doesn't. And I think he's kind of torn between thinking, should I pile in, but I'll probably, you know, our ships will get sunk as well. Should I try and escape with what I can get
清晨的凌晨，一点钟、两点钟左右。是的，我想大约两点钟吧。基本上到最后他们实在是太累了。这对在“纪尧姆·泰尔号”上的皮埃尔-维勒讷夫来说是个好消息，因为他基本上——我的意思是，你刚才说法国人也打了一场好仗。我的意思是，他其实没有，他本可以上来帮忙的，但他没有。我想他在想，我是不是该加入进去，但我可能会，你知道的，我们的船也会被击沉。我是不是应该带着能从废墟中弄到的东西逃跑
from the ruin?" And so ultimately he decides that that's what he'll do. And so his own ship, the Guillaume Tell and the Jean Roiaux, which is another one, they get away, but all the others, they're either sunk or captured. And it is exactly the battle of annihilation that Nelson had wanted. Nelson hasn't lost a single ship and it's an astonishing victory. So 11 ships of the line, two frigates, a brig either captured or destroyed. And only Villeneuve really lives to fight another day and of course he will live to fight another day because he will be the commander who is defeated at the Battle of Trafalgar. And this is so important because from this moment onwards, the gossip in Paris is that
呢？”所以最终他决定这就是他要做的。于是他自己的船“纪尧姆·泰尔号”和另一艘“让·罗约号”逃掉了，但所有其他的船，要么被击沉，要么被俘虏。这正是纳尔逊一直想要的歼灭战。纳尔逊没有损失一艘船，这是一个惊人的胜利。所以11艘战列舰，2艘护卫舰，1艘双桅纵帆船，要么被俘，要么被毁。只有维勒讷夫真正活下来去迎接另一天，当然他会活到另一天，因为他将成为在特拉法加海战中被击败的指挥官。这非常重要，因为从这一刻起，巴黎的八卦就是
Villeneuve was frightened and he ran away and he instead of standing and fighting, he fled. Now Villeneuve was very upset by this. His argument was, you know, I got away and everybody else was destroyed or captured. I didn't behave dishonorably, I did the right thing. But this will play a part in the Battle of Trafalgar and in his decision. Because he doesn't want to retreat again, does he? Exactly. So Nelson lost about just over 200 men, the French lost somewhere between 2000 and 4000. And as you said, Tom, this is the most cataclysmic defeat for the French Navy. The most obvious effect is on Napoleon Bonaparte. He was in Cairo at his headquarters, which was in a kind of converted Ottoman townhouse.
维勒讷夫害怕了，他逃跑了，他没有坚守并战斗，而是逃跑了。现在维勒讷夫对此感到非常难过。他的论点是，你知道的，我逃出去了，而其他所有人都被摧毁或俘虏了。我没有做出不光彩的行为，我做了正确的事情。但这将在特拉法加海战中发挥作用，并影响他的决定。因为他不想再次撤退，对吧？没错。所以纳尔逊损失了略多于200人，法国人损失了2000到4000人。正如你所说，汤姆，这是法国海军最惨重的失败。最直接的影响是在拿破仑·波拿巴身上。他在开罗的总部，那是一栋由奥斯曼联排别墅改造的建筑。
One thing I was wondering, I don't know whether you've come across this, I can't remember reading it, is whether by this point, Napoleon has a sense that Nelson is an adversary to fear, to respect. Because he ends up having kind of bust of Nelson, doesn't he, on his mantelpiece. Yes, he does. Presumably, this is the moment where he really thinks actually, here is a worthy adversary. I think so, yes. Would he have even known of Nelson's heroism at the Battle of Capus and Vincent? He might have heard of it, but he probably wouldn't have.
有一件事我一直在想，我不知道你是否遇到过，我不记得读到过，那就是到了这个时候，拿破仑是否感觉到纳尔逊是一个令人畏惧、值得尊敬的对手？因为他最后在壁炉台上摆放了一个纳尔逊的半身像，不是吗？是的，他确实有。据推测，这就是他真正认为实际上，这是一个值得尊敬的对手的时刻。我想是的，没错。他甚至会知道纳尔逊在圣文生角战役中的英雄主义吗？他可能听说过，但可能不会。
Probably he doesn't, actually. Because the news comes to him and it is said that he basically takes the note and puts it aside. But the next morning, he's talking to his lieutenants, Napoleon this is, and he says to them, it seems you like this country. Well that's lucky because now we don't have any fleet to take us back to Europe. And actually the remarkable thing is he stays for another year in the Middle East. He delays the inevitable by launching his disastrous Gaza campaign, which basically sees the French army causing utter carnage in Gaza and then wandering hither and thither across the desert, stricken by plague and behaving very badly.
可能他真的不知道。因为消息传到据称他基本上把便条放在一边。但第二天早上，拿破仑在与他的中尉们交谈时，他对他们说，看来你们很喜欢这个国家。那真是幸运，因为现在我们没有任何舰队能带我们回欧洲了。事实上，引人注目的是他在中东又呆了一年。他发动了灾难性的加沙战役，推迟了不可避免的结局，这基本上导致法军在加沙造成了极大的大屠杀，然后四处游荡穿过沙漠，饱受瘟疫折磨，表现非常糟糕。
Basically Napoleon, this is the first time that he does what would be a feature of his career. He scuttles back to France, abandoninging his army and he leaves them in the desert. So 40,000 men who went to Egypt with Napoleon, 15,000 were killed or very seriously wounded and the rest all ended up as British prisoners. So the whole campaign, which is, as you said, an extraordinary landmark in human history, is nevertheless an utter disaster. And from the British point of view, brilliant, because India is now secured as well.
基本上拿破仑，这是他第一次做出将成为他职业生涯特征的事情。他仓皇逃回法国，抛弃了他的军队，把他们留在了沙漠里。所以跟随拿破仑去埃及的4万名士兵中，1.5万人被杀或受重伤，其余的人最终都成了英国的俘虏。所以整个战役，正如你所说，是人类历史上一个非凡的里程碑，然而却是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。从英国的角度来看，这太棒了，因为印度现在也安全了。
Exactly. But beyond that, the Battle of the Nile, naval historians have often said, this is a real turning point in world history. Ben Wilson and his history of the Royal Navy says it was undoubtedly the greatest victory in British naval history because the French had control of the Mediterranean and they have definitively lost it. Napoleon's army is trapped. It has broken the image of Napoleon's invincibility and it has permanently shattered the confidence of France's Navy. There was a French academic study in 1998 and they wrote about the Battle of the Nile. The Battle of the Nile is a battle of which French historians
没错。但除此之外，海军历史学家经常说，尼罗河战役是世界历史上真正的转折点。本·威尔逊在他的《皇家海军史》中说，这无疑是英国海军史上最伟大的胜利，因为法国人控制了地中海，而他们彻底失去了对地中海的控制。拿破仑的军队被困住了。它打破了拿破仑战无不胜的形象，并彻底粉碎了法国海军的信心。1998年有一项法国学术研究，他们撰写了关于尼罗河战役的文章。尼罗河战役是法国历史学家
never speak. So this presumably is why Theo had never heard of it. Theo never heard of it. Oh come on Theo, that's poor. But I think more than that, so obviously it deals a devastating blow to the confidence of the French Navy, but of course it also boosts the confidence of the French Navy. But of course, it also boosts the confidence of those European powers who had withdrawn from the fight against France and who now kind of think maybe France isn't invincible after all. Exactly. And of course, that is the great geopolitical goal for Britain, isn't it? It's not just to save India and to reestablish British naval control
绝口不提的一场战役。所以这大概就是为什么西奥（Theo）从未听说过它的原因。西奥从未听说过。哦，拜托，西奥，这太逊了。但我觉得不仅如此，所以很显然，它对法国海军的信心造成了毁灭性的打击，但当然，它也提升了那些退出对法作战的欧洲列强的信心，他们现在觉得也许法国人并非不可战胜。绝对的。当然，那是英国伟大的地缘政治目标，不是吗？不仅仅是为了拯救印度，重新确立英国海军对
over the Mediterranean, but to try and get the land-based allies that it needs, because it's not enough for Britain to avoid defeat, it needs actually victory against France and that means that they need allies with armies. Exactly. Britain needs to keep winning victories at sea to get the Austrians and the Prussians back into the war to prosecute the defeat of the French on land. And of course that will take a very long time, but in the long run, the British strategy does work. So Nelson holds a service of thanksgiving aboard the vanguard.
地中海的控制，而是为了争取它需要的陆上盟友，因为对英国来说，避免失败是不够的，它实际上需要战胜法国，这意味着他们需要拥有军队的盟友。没错。英国需要不断在海上取得胜利，以让奥地利人和普鲁士人重新加入战争，在陆上彻底击败法国。当然，这需要很长时间，但从长远来看，英国的战略确实起作用了。所以纳尔逊在“先锋号”上举行了一场感恩礼拜。
And as a good vicar's son, he says, this is God's victory. The hand of God was visibly pressed on the French. It was not in the power of man to gain such a victory. So an Achilles, but a Christian Achilles. Yes, but his officers are in no doubt. As Sommaray writes to Napoleon, it was the most glorious and complete victory ever obtained, the just recompense of your zeal. And it has pleased Providence to give you the sight of these vile miscreants who have now received the just punishment due
作为一个优秀的牧师之子，他说，这是上帝的胜利。上帝之手明显压制了法国人。人类没有能力取得这样的胜利。所以他是阿喀琉斯，但却是一位基督徒阿喀琉斯。是的，但他的军官们毫不怀疑。正如索马雷兹写给拿破仑的那样，这是有史以来最辉煌、最彻底的胜利，是对你们热忱的公正回报。上天很高兴让你们看到这些卑鄙的恶棍，他们现在受到了应有的惩罚，
to their past crimes. But Sommaray summary is no doubt, it's Nelson's personal victory. He calls a meeting of the captains and they say we will found an Egyptian club in honor of the victory. When we get the club room, we will have a portrait of Nelson and we will hang it there and we will club together ourselves to buy Nelson a sword to thank him for leading us to this amazing, amazing triumph. And Dominic, just to say that Nelson likewise looks out for his captains, because of course we mentioned how Trowbridge doesn't take part in the battle because he's been stranded on this shoal. And so in due course, when medallions are given to the various captains who had fought in
这是他们过去罪行的报应。但索马雷兹毫无疑问，这是纳尔逊个人的胜利。他召集船长们开会，他们说我们将成立一个埃及俱乐部来纪念这场胜利。当我们拥有俱乐部房间时，我们将挂上纳尔逊的画像，我们会自己凑钱给纳尔逊买一把剑，感谢他带领我们走向这个惊人、惊人的胜利。多米尼克，顺便说一句，纳尔逊同样照顾他的船长们，因为当然我们提到特罗布里奇是如何没有参加战斗的，因为他被困在这片浅滩上。因此，在适当的时候，当勋章颁发给参加过
the Battle of the Nile, there was a move to deny Trowbridge his medallion and Nelson was absolutely insistent that he have one. That is nice. So that's the band of brothers in operation. Yeah. And Nelson, you know, he's such a romantic deep down, isn't he? That band of brothers stuff that lots of people might scoff at. He loves that.
尼罗河战役的各船长时，有人试图剥夺特罗布里奇的勋章，而纳尔逊坚决要求他必须有一枚。那太好了。所以这就是兄弟连在发挥作用。是的。而纳尔逊，你知道，他骨子里是那么浪漫，不是吗？很多人可能会嗤之以鼻的兄弟连那一套。他很喜欢这个。
And you can just imagine his officers telling him about this Egyptian club they're going to set up with a picture of him. And you can imagine kind of the manly tears springing into his eyes, Tom. He would have absolutely adored that. The news reaches Gibraltar and then Cadiz and then it travels to the Admiralty in London. It arrives on the 2nd of October, my birthday. A messenger is sent to the King, George III. I love this.
你能想象他的军官们告诉他他们要建立这个埃及俱乐部，里面挂着他的照片。你可以想象那种男子汉的热泪涌上他的眼眶，汤姆。他绝对会对此爱不释手。消息传到直布罗陀，然后是加的斯，然后传到伦敦的海军部。它在10月2日到达，那是我的生日。一个信使被派往国王乔治三世那里。我喜欢这个。
This is almost my favourite episode in the whole history of Nelson. The whole history of history. The whole history of history. There's nothing better than this. The messenger to George III is crossing Hounslow Heath and is stopped by a highwayman. And when the messenger tells the highwayman what the packet contains, which is news of Nelson's victory at the Nile, the highwayman, without a packet contains, which is news of Nelson's victory at the Nile, the highwayman, without a word, hands him back the package and says, be on your way.
这几乎是我在纳尔逊整个历史中最喜欢的一集。整个历史的历史。整个历史的历史。没有什么比这更好的了。派往乔治三世的信使正在穿过豪恩斯洛荒原，被一名拦路强盗拦住了。当信使告诉强盗包裹里装的是什么时，也就是纳尔逊在尼罗河大捷的消息，强盗一言不发地把包裹还给他，并说，
You know, what an amazing story. There are bonfires and bells and fireworks. In every theatre people are singing rural Britannia. It is the most extraordinary moment of national celebration. And relief. And relief, of course. It's the kind of El of national celebration. And relief. And relief, of course. It's the kind of El Alamein, isn't it? It's El Alamein and Mafeking and Port Stanley rolled into one.
上路吧。你知道，多么惊人的故事。到处都是篝火、钟声和烟花。在每个剧院里，人们都在高唱《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》。这是国家庆祝最非凡的时刻。还有解脱。当然还有解脱。这就像是国家的阿拉曼战役，不是吗？这是阿拉曼、迈费金和斯坦利港三合一。
Nelson is awarded a barony. He's a bit disappointed. That's the thing with Nelson. He's always after more. He hoped he would be made a Viscount. But he hasn't got the money for it, has he? He hasn't got the money. This is the reason that he can't support a Viscount. But he hasn't got the money for it has he? He hasn't got the money. This is the reason that he can't support a Viscount's lifestyle. However, he's not going to go home
纳尔逊被授予男爵头衔。他有点失望。这就是纳尔逊的问题。他总是追求更多。他希望自己能被封为子爵。但他没有这个钱，对吧？他没有钱。这就是他无法维持子爵生活方式的原因。但他没有这个钱，对吧？他没有钱。这就是他无法维持子爵生活方式的原因。然而，他并不打算
just yet. He now divides his fleet into three. So one group will remain at Alexandria to blockade the French. And people who love blockades, Tom you've said how much you like blockades, perhaps you'd like to treat them to the story of that blockade in a bonus episode at some future point. Yeah, that'd be fun. I won't be there for that recording because I find blockades very boring. A second group escort the captured French ships to Gibraltar so they can claim the prize money. Really important of course for anyone in the Royal Navy.
现在就回家。他现在把他的舰队分成三部分。所以一组将留在亚历山大港封锁法国人。那些喜欢封锁的人，汤姆，你已经说过你有多喜欢封锁，也许你愿意在未来某个时候的彩蛋节目中用那个封锁的故事款待他们。是的，那会很有趣。我不会去参加那个录音，因为我觉得封锁太无聊了。第二组护送被捕获的法国船只到直布罗陀，这样他们就可以领取奖金。当然，这对皇家海军的任何人来说都非常重要。
And finally, Nelson himself will take the battered Vanguard Alexander and Culloden to Naples so that Britain's only real allies in the Mediterranean can hear the news of the battle at first hand. And dominate not just the King and Queen in Naples but of course the the British and voice of William Hamilton and his delightful wife Lady Hamilton. Now this is the end of the first season of Nelson. We'll be returning to his story in the spring. Would you like a little teaser, Tom, for the second season of Horatio Nelson? Yeah, I'd love one. And so, on the 22nd of September, the Vanguard limped into the Bay of Naples.
最后，纳尔逊本人将带着饱经风雨的“先锋号”、“亚历山大号”和“卡洛登号”前往那不勒斯，以便英国在地中海唯一的真正盟友能够第一手听到战役的消息。多米尼克，不仅仅是不勒斯的国王和王后，当然还有英国使节威廉·汉密尔顿和他迷人的妻子汉密尔顿夫人。现在这是纳尔逊第一季的结束。我们将在春季回归他的故事。汤姆，你想为《霍雷肖·纳尔逊》第二季听一点预告片吗？是的，我很想听。因此，9月22日，“先锋号”蹒跚驶入那不勒斯湾。
Ahead lay the third largest city in Europe, simmering with danger. Although Nelson could hardly have known it, one of the darkest chapters in his life was about to begin. So that is from your book, Dominic Nelson, Hero of the Seas. And it's the perfect Christmas present for readers of all ages you've written down here. Now, as you said, we will be back continuing the story of Nelson in the spring. Obviously, we won't be covering the darkest chapter in Nelson's life. I really don't think we need to bother with that.
前方是欧洲第三大城市，弥漫着危险的气息。尽管纳尔逊几乎不可能知道，他一生中最黑暗的章节之一即将开始。所以这段话来自你的书，《纳尔逊：海洋英雄》，多米尼克。你这里写着，这是送给所有年龄段读者的绝佳圣诞礼物。现在，正如你所说，我们将在春季回归并继续纳尔逊的故事。很显然，我们不会涉及纳尔逊一生中最黑暗的章节。我真的觉得我们没必要操心那个。
You don't reckon we'll do Naples at all? No, we don't need to bother with that. So we will be back with the Battle of Copenhagen. Another brilliant victory for Nelson. I have to say, I think we will be doing Naples. So people may want to skip that one if they don't want to hear anything bad about Nelson. So if you can't wait, we have actually touched on most of the episodes that follow on from the Battle of the Nile in various previous episodes of the rest of history. So William Hamilton, whose wife Emma Hamilton will be playing a leading role in the darkest chapter
你觉得我们根本不会去那不勒斯？不，我们不需要操心那个。所以我们将带着哥本哈根战役回归。纳尔逊的又一次辉煌胜利。我必须说，我认为我们还是会去那不勒斯。所以如果人们不想听到任何关于纳尔逊的坏话，可能会想跳过那一集。所以如果你等不及了，实际上我们在《余下的历史》之前的各种节目中已经触及了尼罗河战役之后的大多数剧集。所以威廉·汉密尔顿，他的妻子爱玛·汉密尔顿将在纳尔逊一生中最黑暗的章节中扮演主角。
in Nelson's life. He was on Love Island 2, so you can hear about him. The Battle of Copenhagen, Nelson's great victory in the Baltic featured in the very early episode we did when we did one on England against Denmark for, it was Euros, wasn't it? Euro 2020. So we've done that and we've done a three-part series on Trafalgar. So you can kind of piece them together, but we will be doing all of these in much more detail in the spring and it continues to be a remarkable and epic story and we will see you then.
他上过《爱情岛》第二季，所以你可以了解他。哥本哈根战役，纳尔逊在波罗的海的伟大胜利，出现在我们早期的一集中，当时我们做了一集关于英格兰对阵丹麦的节目，那是欧洲杯，对吧？2020年欧洲杯。所以我们做过这些，我们还做过关于特拉法加的三集系列节目。所以你可以把它们拼凑起来，但我们将在春季更详细地探讨所有这些，这将继续是一个非凡而史诗般的故事，我们到时候见。
Okay. But our next episode, we will still be in the Near East, but we will be exploring a time millennia before the age of Nelson as we go in search of the world's oldest city. So bye bye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。但在我们的下一集中，我们仍将在近东，但我们将探索一个比纳尔逊时代早几千年的时代，我们将去寻找世界上最古老的城市。所以拜拜。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。